salut tout le monde c'est envergure et
voici un nouveau podcast de présentation
d'un des prospects de la draft 2023 NBA
un prospect qui a eu une ascension très
rapide dans les big boards et les Mogs
draft cette année il s'agit de Kobe
basket
comme Kobe je sais pas comment on dit 21
septembre 2003 c'est sa date de
naissance 1m96 88 kg 2 m 03 d'envergure
de bras il jouait à Michigan cette année
en compagnie de jet Howard un autre
prospect que nous avons sur notre board
et sous les ordres de Diwan Award pour
en parler Thomas Mathias salut les gars
salut salut
et donc Thomas c'est toi qui va qui va
commencer avec la biographie le parcours
de code ou Kobe je sais pas on va voir
comment tu dis bœuf kine avant jusqu'à
cette draft on va dire et puis après on
parlera du contexte de ses qualités etc
alors Kobi buffing personnellement c'est
comme ça que je le dis il est né le 21
septembre 2003 donc il est très très
jeune pour un sophomore n'a même pas
encore 20 ans il aura tout juste 20 ans
en début de la saison donc c'est déjà un
très bon point pour lui c'est un
prospect un prospect assez intéressant
depuis maintenant quelques années depuis
son High School durant son enfant il a
été déjà depuis très longtemps fan de
Michigan mais premièrement c'est un fan
de football et c'est à partir de 7 ans
qu'il est vraiment tombé dans le basket
il a commencé à y jouer très
sérieusement j'ai pas trouvé de choses
très intéressantes sur son endroit
familial n'a pas l'air d'avoir de grands
sportifs dans sa famille mais en tant
que originaire du Michigan donc il a
tout de suite rêvé de jouer pour pour
cette fac il est natif de la ville de
grande rapide qui est d'ailleurs la même
que des vignes Boutières donc voilà
c'est la petite anecdote du jour
comme ils peuvent Ken donc il a les
mêmes initiales et le même prénom que
continuer de faire monter sa cote sa
cote a encore repris un petit boost au
niveau du combat
des mesures plus intéressantes que l'on
le pensait il était mesuré donc à 6
cartes 25 100 chaussures alors qu'il
était mis partout à 6 4 c'est
généralement ça fait que avec chaussures
donc il a un bon 6 50 chaussures ce qui
est parfait pour lui qui est un goût
donc il pourra jouer les deux positions
en NBA elle était annoncé un peu moins
de 80 kilos au compagne il était plus à
85 et il a pas une envergure très très
ronde quasiment 6 8 c'est pas très très
grand pour sa taille mais ça reste tout
à fait honnête mais annoncé plus grand
que sa poésie plus grand que l'on ne
pensait pardon et plus lourd surtout
pour lui qui était encore assez froide
c'est un très bon point en plus pour
cette fin de saison pour lui
et donc tu le disais ça cote est monté à
tel point que nous chez envergure on a
peut-être pas encore attrapé le train au
moment où on enregistre 31 mai puisqu'on
a 34e alors que tous les autres moque
draft ou bigboard long top 20 11e chez
the athlétique 18e chez ispienne dixième
chez the Ringer que faisait comme bebeuf
Kin quel rôle il avait cette année à
Michigan dans l'attaque et la défense de
Michigan c'est toi Mathias notre
spécialiste big time donc la conférence
dans laquelle il évoluait qui va nous
parler de ça
je vous confirme c'est bien Kobe parce
que j'avais vu que ses parents l'avaient
appelé Kobe car ils sont fan de Kobe
donc
c'est un Guard qui a qui était enfin qui
est cette saison mais qui la saison
dernière était freshman et jouait que à
peine 10 minutes par match donc c'était
vraiment très peu et là donc l'explosé
il a aussi profité de la blessure de du
Guard qui était censé être titulaire
cette saison c'est jaline Lewin je sais
pas trop comment on le prononce un peu
compliqué en tout cas c'est un transfert
ouais c'était un transfert de Princeton
et donc il a profité de la blessure de
celui-là pour pour vraiment dominer sur
le parcours de Michigan qui en plus n'a
pas beaucoup beaucoup de Gordes à part
Doug McDaniel qui est aussi un flashman
avec qui du coup il a pas il a partagé
le ballon cette saison et donc cette
saison il était dans une équipe de
Michigan qui était ni bonne ni mauvaise
un peu dans dans le ventre moude sa
conférence
toujours autour de Hunter Dickinson
la star de l'équipe qui d'ailleurs à
partir l'année prochaine et donc il a
beaucoup joué avec Hunter Dickinson
surtout sur pick and roll interditsen
c'est un 5 pour presser un 5 fuyant 5 un
peu old school
et donc le
la majeur partie du jeu de Michigan
c'est surtout sur pick and roll entre
kobekin et Hunter Dickinson donc voilà
un peu pour le contexte et défensivement
et ce qu'il avait des la tâche de se
taper le plus fort attaquant advers sur
les postes arrière ou est-ce que
justement il se reposer un peu
il a de plus en plus pris les meilleurs
défenseurs adversaires parce que c'est
pas un mauvais défenseur on va le voir
après mais c'est vrai que de plus en
plus le coach lui a fait confiance et la
mise sur les meilleurs joueurs
adversaires
un schéma un peu conservateur tu l'as
dit à l'ancienne avec
Hunter Dickinson en attaque ce qui
laisse un des seuls chiffres rouges
qu'on voit dans son profil sur bartorvix
et rebond offensif mais en fait il y a
là quasiment jamais donc ceci peut
expliquer cela
qu'est-ce qu'on drave parce que vraiment
là on parle d'un joueur qui peut encore
une fois être un exemple de bah parfois
c'est bien d'attendre une saison avant
de se présenter à la draft c'est
sophomore qui qui est close dans leur
deuxième année parce qu'ils ne sont tout
simplement pas murs avant et là une
saison assez exceptionnelle de Kobe de
kobekin et donc Thomas pourquoi
pourquoi on draft quel est son ticket
d'entrée en NBA
alors pour moi Kobe Bustin n'a pas un
ticket d'entrée en NBA très précis je
dirais que c'est tout simplement l'un
des guardes les plus complètes cette
draft comme ils peuvent gagner il a
quasiment aucun défaut majeur dans son
jeu il s'est vraiment tout faire et ça
se voit rien quand même par ces stats
cette saison à Michigan c'est 14 matchs
plus de 4 bons c'est trois passes c'est
plus d'une interception c'est quasiment
un bloc c'est efficace à deux points
c'est plutôt efficace à trois points
avec pas mal de progrès par rapport à
son à sa première année même s'il y
avait très peu de volume c'est bon
lancer également et c'est bon en défense
comme comme Mathias le disait
précédemment donc c'est vraiment un
joueur très complet sur le poste de
garde c'est un joueur qui a pu jouer
ovball et qui a pu sanctionner avec sa
papa de gauche vu que oui les gauchers
en lapin Cordi donc ça un guide qui
s'est porté la balle qui s'est initié du
pic and roll qui est capable de Drive
des deux côtés même si il a un corps pas
mal dépendant de sa main gauche
notamment dans ses finitions il était
très efficace aussi à 68% au cercle de
cette saison c'est vraiment énorme sur
un volume en plus vraiment intéressant
c'est un joueur qui récolte pas encore
énormément de lancer mais on le sait la
raquette de Michigan et comme on l'a dit
pas mal bouchée par unteur Dickinson
donc pour les dry ça peut être un peu
compliqué par
moments qui peut tirer trois points il
est capable de créer son tir également à
mes distances et surtout un très bon
connecteur en fait c'est un mec qui va
faire les bons choix qui perd assez peu
là-bas il a une virgule 5 paire de balle
de moyenne il me semble cette année donc
c'est vraiment intéressant il fait jouer
les autres c'est un joueur collectifs il
peut jouer un deux à Michigan il jouait
les deux positions sortez c'est lui qui
portait plus la balle quand tout était
là et joue un peu plus sans ballon de
façon le jeu est vraiment centré autour
d'un Hunter Dickinson donc même les
Gaulois je suis vraiment sans ballon et
qu'il est capable de passer il est
capable de dribbler les capables de
tirer les capables d'attaquer les
cercles avec ferrocité c'est un athlète
vraiment intéressant c'est un joueur
assez rapide ils m'ont bien au dunk
malgré sa taille pas forcément
impressionnant c'est quand même un
joueur qui a tenté 12 fois cette saison
donc c'est plutôt correct même si c'est
pas incroyable comme on l'a dit c'est
pas le joueur qui allait le plus au
Cercle non plus vu le système de de
Michigan mais donc un genre très complet
vraiment très très peu de défauts et qui
qui est plutôt qui est plutôt vraiment
bon partout
être bon partout parfois ça ne suffit
pas pour jouer en NBA parce qu'il faut
avoir le le l'atout qui nous fait dont
le coach a besoin à ce moment-là est-ce
que tu envoies un toi Mathias ou est-ce
qu'au contraire tu vois comme Thomas
je suis quand même plutôt d'accord avec
Thomas maintenant si je dois trouver
un domaine dans lequel je trouve
vraiment bon je pense que c'est son
dribble parce qu'il est capable de
dribbler avec les deux mains il est très
à l'aise ça lui permet de
s'ouvrir des chemins assez facilement au
Cercle parce qu'il est quand même c'est
un bon joueur pour la finition au cercle
et donc avoir les deux mains ça lui
permet beaucoup de choses ou de scorer
de trouver ses partenaires aussi de
perdre très peu de ballons donc c'est
vraiment ce que je préfère chez lui
après on l'a pas souligné mais bon c'est
un sophobore mais ça reste un très très
jeune joueur l'année dernière il a
quasiment quasi pas joué parce qu'il
avait à peine 18 ans donc sophomore mais
quand même très jeune il est encore plus
jeune que le freshmangate l'autre groupe
qui joue donc voilà
et sur sur son tir on peut s'arrêter
là-dessus parce que c'est important
quand on est un Guard NBA est-ce que
l'un comme l'autre va peut-être Mathias
d'abord vous vous achetez le le tir de
Kobi Buffin au niveau supérieur
il y a quand même des questions parce
que sur le en tout cas sur le tir
extérieur parce que le pourcentage reste
correct mais pas incroyable non plus il
a 35% sur un peu plus de trois
tentatives c'est pas exceptionnel donc
il y a des questions par contre sur du
migraine là il est vraiment beaucoup
plus à l'aise il le crée son shoot il
est vraiment dans sa zone de confort
c'est vraiment plus un joueur 2012 un
peu à l'image d'un giant
dans la mqv donc pour moi il y a des
petites questions sur le shoot extérieur
mais c'est pas non plus très alarmant
Thomas kelskill tu développerait en
priorité chez lui pour pour justement
qu'il devienne incontournable dans un
roster NBA et puis je vous laisse tous
les deux penser à des joueurs qui
avaient à peu près les mêmes qualités de
all around et qu'ils ont qui ont réussi
à s'imposer un peu la même gabarit etc
qu'on réussit à s'imposer sans avoir le
skill qui fait tout basculer quoi donc
d'abord ce qu'il a développé pour toi
Thomas
pour moi le skills a développé en fait
il y a deux possibilités soit ça devient
un joueur qui est vraiment qu'à son
plafond et ça devint un joueur encore
plus fort humble qui travaille son pull
up qui travaille son plein de making
pourquoi plus porter la balle en NBA
sinon pour être vraiment plus viable
dans une line 9 NBA et pour vraiment
progresser énormément comme elle l'a
fait cette année pour moi c'est vraiment
sur le 3 points personnellement j'y
crois il a un pourcentage à trois points
plutôt solide c'est avec une matière
c'est plus de 35% sur quatre tentatives
en match il est très bon moment c'est
Franck
85%, et les bons amis distance il a un
bon touché au cercle il a vraiment une
belle mécanique j'aime bien son
alignement il est vraiment bien aligné
sur le panier là un bon mouvement de
hanche même sur des feuilles de web pour
bien se remettre en position il a
dépensé etc il rentre bien dedans donc
personnellement j'achète l'obside au
niveau du shoot et si ça tient un bon
shooter en NBA qu'il arrive à augmenter
son volume et que la réussite avec ça
peut vraiment être un joueur très
intéressant car ça va le rendre encore
plus valuable pour jouer à côté d'un
autre plongeur vu personnellement je
pense pas qu'il est suffisamment de de
scoring sur pull-up et de capacité à se
correr tout simplement et à faire jouer
les autres assez fort pour porter la
balle sur un très gros volume une bière
donc je le vois plus comment joueur
comme un joueur de complément à côté
d'un autre fort World qui profite des
dégâts à l'âge pour ensuite faire
d'autres décalages pour faire son
scoring pour shooter et pour apporter en
défense donc je pense vraiment si
Provins à ça à trois points ça il va
pouvoir vraiment va pouvoir vraiment
sanctionner les espaces qui vont que
value offrir la star qui joue un
potentiellement à côté de lui dans un
bacon avec la boîte très très
intéressant pour les pros à proprement
et alors défensivement qu'est-ce que ça
donne Mathias parce que moi ça me fait
penser joueur de complément à côté d'une
star ça fait penser à des profils un peu
à là à la Diane Tony Melton sur de
joueurs là mais qui sont quand même
souvent très fort défensivement
qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu as à
dire sur ces capacités défensives on l'a
dit il est long sans être très long il
est plutôt grand pour sa position voilà
comment ça se passe au niveau de la
mobilité de l'intelligence
ah ouais ouais non mais la défense c'est
clairement de ses points forts de toute
façon on est sur un vrai joueur donc
comme tu l'as dit long très mobile
qui arrive facilement à contourner les
écrans à rester au contact que son
adversaire
en un contre un il est très bon en off
bol aussi il y a pas grand chose à dire
ça défense elle est elle est bonne
maintenant c'est un joueur encore très
frêle il fait à peine 80 kg je pense que
quand il va arriver en NBA ça va se
ressentir donc il va falloir qu'il
s'épêtise et qui prennent un peu en
masse là il fait 88
[Musique]
Thomas dit 85 dollars mais bref il a
pris du poids quoi
ok parce que je le trouve quand même
très frêle maintenant le cuit le cuit
défensif il est là il y a pas il y a pas
vraiment le souci et ouais j'aime bien
la comparaison avec un de Anthony Melton
ou un joueur Hollande mais qui aura un
impact en tout cas défensivement ok
au niveau de sa mentalité
Mathias qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
penses de qu'est-ce que tu as vu cette
année de des attitudes sur le terrain ou
sur le banc des déclarations etc
c'est un joueur qui déjà de base devait
pas être forcément titulaire donc qui au
fur et au fur et à mesure de la saison
il a pris confiance en lui il a il a
récupéré des qualités un petit peu de
leader je regardais un petit peu sur le
site de Michigan ça disait de lui que
c'était un joueur très discret qui
parlait assez peu mais sur le terrain
c'est autre chose il sait prendre ses
responsabilités il est patient avec le
ballon il organise il est il est calme
c'est un genre très calme donc
il n'y a pas vraiment de Red Flag au
niveau de son comportement c'est un
joueur très actif impliqué peut-être
qu'il peut l'être plus notamment au
rebond mais en tout cas je trouve que
c'est un joueur qui a l'air d'avoir la
tête sur les épaules sur le terrain en
tout cas
comment on se projette déjà l'année
prochaine et puis ensuite on parlera des
probable meilleur scénarios dans à la
fin de son contrat Rocky donc trois
quatre ans mais Thomas déjà l'année
prochaine qu'est-ce qu'on va lui faire
faire et qu'est-ce qu'on devrait lui
faire faire
si il montre il continue de progresser
au tiers ça peut vraiment être
intéressant et je pense qu'il qui
pourrait faire il pourrait faire du taf
et rester sur le terrain NBA plutôt
rapidement sur des séquences où il
pourra tirer ou pourra faciliter le jeu
et pourra défendre sur tes quoi adverse
même si par séquence s'apprête un peu
compliqué si il doit défendre des
joueurs un peu fort pour lui un peu trop
imposant physiquement mais je pense
vraiment qu'ils peuvent avoir une carte
à jouer plutôt rapidement OK et Mathias
toi quel meilleur scénario tu vois
justement dans son développement
jusqu'où il pourrait aller pour toi quel
est son plafond
je pense qu'il va je pense que c'est
bien pour lui d'avoir pas mal
d'aller-retours en Gillig dans un
premier temps on l'a dit c'est un joueur
très jeune qui a besoin de se développer
encore et de se développer surtout un
peut-être un aspect un peu élite parce
que là il est sur mais il lui faut un
vrai ticket d'entrée et un vrai secteur
dans lequel il peut apporter précisément
dans une équipe
se développer angélique avoir des
shooters autour de lui lui donner la
balle en main avec avec des bises avec
des bigs pardon qui savent lui poser des
bons écrans parce que c'est un excellent
joueur de Pick & roll et et d'écran donc
ouais je pense que c'est un projet
encore pour l'instant mais ça peut être
un joueur très intéressant un bon rôle
player comme tu disais tout à l'heure à
poser à côté d'un d'un prix Marie
Wallender NBA
ok vous y croyez l'un comme l'autre
rapidos
moi je suis
un peu dubitatif je sais pas trop j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu irisk
midrewart ok tu as l'impression qu'il
est un peu surcoté par les moques
américaines quand je le vois en loterie
ou un petit peu quand même ok Thomas moi
j'aime beaucoup et j'ai beaucoup regardé
Michigan très tôt dans la saison pour ce
sujet j'avais déjà beaucoup de gâteaux
Word à IMG du coup j'étais très pressé
de le voir du coup je l'ai je l'ai
rapidement dans mon premier tour vu que
c'est un genre que la performait très
très tôt dans la saison et vu qu'il a
continué de progresser il est 18 chez
moi actuellement pour moi le voir
loterie au Clos c'est vraiment pas
déconnant je trouve qu'il est vraiment
très très complet des deux côtés du
terrain handball of bol si il continue
de progresser je trouve que c'est un
joueur qui a dépend fondamentaux c'est
un bonjour sur le terrain c'est un bon
soldat c'est un genre qui est qui écoute
ce qu'on lui dit j'ai l'impression que
c'est un vrai bon coéquipier un joueur
qui sera censé être dans une équipe en
NBA du coup j'aime beaucoup le joueur je
trouve qu'il est encore pas mal
potentiel à taper il est vraiment très
très jeune et là tous ces skills à
continuer de peaufiner donc moi j'aime
énormément je l'achète je l'achète
plutôt assez haut je trouve que c'est ça
peut vraiment être un bon goût en NBA il
a vraiment le profil même s'il sera
toujours limité par si il fait pas 2 m 3
pour défendre sur des éléments des
éléphants sur un joueur qui va pouvoir
défendre du Gold qui va pouvoir shooter
qui va pouvoir passer qui va pouvoir
driver faut qu'il progresse un peu sur
sa main droite je la trouve un peu
limité au cercle et finit souvent main
gauche côté droit donc par moment ça
peut lui le fermer des fenêtres de tir
même si il était très efficace social
donc je trouve que c'est un vrai bon
joueur qui a un plancher assez
intéressant et qui a encore pas mal
d'Open pour être un très bonjour NBA je
trouve
c'était notre présentation l'essentiel
sur kobeuf King Jouarre de Michigan
Candida à la draft NBA 2023 vous avez
tous les autres podcasts il y en a un
par jour qui sort pendant le mois de
juin tous les autres podcasts
disponibles sur les plateformes d'écoute
sur Youtube également notre big board
sur envergure.co ainsi que les fiches
prospects avec photos description et
mensurations et parfois scouting report
ciao tout le monde